i don't think we have a meaningful first
amendment in this country in just a few
short years if we do nothing if we're
too lazy fair frankly about big tech you
go to applebee's or some family
restaurant you look at
dinner table conversations or what ought
to be conversations among family members
and every kid has his own ipad and
they're just like glued to it
[Music]
we're joined on the line by blake
masters he's running for the senate in
arizona against mark kelly his
background is that he is the head of
field capital multi-billion dollar firm
that invests in new technology companies
and the field foundation a non-profit
foundation promoting science and
innovation and of course he co-authored
the number one new york times bestseller
zero to one with peter thiel it is an
excellent book it has sold more than
three million copies
blake thanks so much for joining the
program really appreciate it
ben it's great to be here thank you
let's talk about why you are bothering
to run for senate uh seems like a really
crappy job i'll be honest with you i've
been asked about running for office
before and it seems pretty miserable
being in the senate dealing with other
senators all day and then having to go
around and fundraise and do all the
things that being a senator requires
what drove you to run for public office
here
right well i'm sure there are miserable
parts but uh hopefully there's some good
parts too mainly i feel like i just have
to do it uh because i feel like we're
losing the country you know um my kids
in some sense will be fine because i've
had a successful business career but
they're on track to grow up in a country
that works much less well than the
country i grew up in right just a few
years ago in the late 80s and 90s
so i think everything is coming apart at
the seams and
it feels i look around in arizona i
think i'm the only person that can
unseat democrat mark kelly and um you
know i'm not sure how much one person
can do but i intend to find out because
if not
if we don't right this ship feel like
america's gone on this current
trajectory in just a few years so blake
let's talk about your opponent mark
kelly and and what is the state of play
in arizona right now so it seems as
though arizona has been moving steadily
from red to blue it's now firmly in the
purple camp and you have a republican
governor you have republican state
legislature but you have two democratic
senators how much of that is a simple
result of the paucity of good republican
candidates and how much of that reflects
sort of underlying changes in the state
of arizona
you know i think it's both but i don't
think arizona's blue uh in fact i know
it's not and i think it's it's it's too
much to even say it's purpling or it's
inevitable or something like this um
arizona is about one-third democrat
one-third republican one-third
independent no affiliation and uh i
think republicans still have a little
advantage but it's basically one third
one third one third now those
independents they want to break right i
think temperamentally they're
conservative to the extent they're
ideological they're conservative but
it's also arizona it's a little bit of a
libertarian state a little bit of an
individualistic state you know we have
that wild west barrie goldwater heritage
and so they're looking to connect with a
candidate personally
you know there's 50 000 people i think
who voted for for governor doug ducey
but then also for kirsten cinema in 2018
and that that group of people mostly in
maricopa county mostly registered
independents that's who's going to
decide the election but here's the thing
we're right on the issues they want a
border wall they just want it
articulated in sort of a right way
they want voter id you know they know
it's not racist to have voter id they
don't want to defund the police they
want more police in their communities in
mesa and chandler and gilbert so i think
we won the right candidate with the
right messenger
arizona can still win
republican
republicans into office already more
with arizona senate candidate blake
masters and justin juan second first
last month an absolute landslide you
made the switch over to pure talk usa
smart move your change overpriced
unlimited plans from verizon att or
t-mobile and then you finally decided it
was time you made the switch
you know that pure talk saves the
average family over 800 a year without
having to sacrifice coverage so here's
what i want you to do you should do what
i did make the switch to pure talk you
can keep your phone keep your number or
get huge discounts on the latest iphones
and androids i got the iphone 12. let me
make this clear you are not sacrificing
coverage with beer talk the reason is
because you are on the exact same
network as one of the big providers the
only difference is those big providers
they're paying a bunch of money for
brick and mortar stores they're paying a
bunch of money for advertising not so
with pure talk usa these guys invest all
of their money into making sure they
have the latest technology and then pass
the savings on to you get unlimited talk
text six gigs of data for just 30 bucks
a month or if you still want unlimited
data you can get that too and you're
still going to be saving a fortune just
dial pound 250 say ben shapiro you'll
save 50 off your first month that is
pound 250. say my name ben shapiro
puretalk is simply smarter wireless so
one of the things that's been happening
in arizona is that the the two
democratic senators uh they make noises
as though they are in the middle kirsten
cinema has actually shown it more than
than mark kelly has she's actually
crossed party lines a little bit kelly
seems to be voting almost
directly down the democratic party line
as opposed to cinema has seen more as as
sort of almost john mccain maverick from
from the democratic party uh so maybe
you can talk a little bit about kelly's
record in the senate
yeah and i do that by distinguishing it
from cinemas right no one thought kelly
was a right winger no one thought he was
gonna you know vote like uh tom cotton
or senator holly or something like this
but kirsten cinema promised to be
independent she promised to buck party
leadership uh as appropriate and i look
she's not a political ally i don't trust
her long term
but she's doing that like thank goodness
she's holding on to the filibuster right
her mention uh kelly made much of the
same noises you know i'll roll up my
sleeves and be independent for arizonans
meanwhile he's voting with chuck schumer
in lockstep
like 98 percent of the time voting
against finishing the border wall voting
for mass amnesty voting for the crazy
spending and infrastructure packages
these democrats put together and so i
think democrats are really good at this
right running moderate candidates who
don't appear to be far left but who are
in fact far left that fits mark kelly to
a t and i think by pointing out the
contrast between him and kirsten cinema
that's one way to show people this is
not the guy you thought you were voting
for
so you know blake it's interesting when
i talk to people from arizona they seem
a
lot of kind of higher ups in the arizona
republican party they seem very
concerned with the voter audits and with
2020 and all of that and it seems to me
that whatever you think happened in 2020
and i've been pretty open that i think
that trump lost the election and that
there are many reasons why he lost the
election but whatever you think of that
i don't see why it behooves the the
arizona republican party to spend the
sort of time and effort they have on on
relitigating 2020 when it seems
perfectly obvious that the future battle
is 2022 2024 and and beyond uh what
where do you think the status is of sort
of the the state republican party at
this point and do they need to to start
looking forward as opposed to looking
backward
well i think you got to do both um and i
don't i don't think that's a cop out i
do think you have to look forward and
win 2022 and you don't do that just by
you know airing sour grapes about 2020
that said you know uh and i don't know
what happened right i look forward to
reading the audit report i think the the
vote margin between trump and biden as
certified was like 10 500 just a few
less um and we know dems ballot harvest
in arizona right we know they do all
these things we're on the margin you can
find votes so even if you don't believe
in in the wilder you know dominion
switched votes stuff um i still think it
behooves us to go and and look and see
is this count accurate how do we know um
if only so that people can see right
president trump said this himself like
let's run the audit let's see if i lost
i lost but let's see right and it feels
like there's an awful lot of gaslighting
blue check journals in arizona want to
tell this base
no this is the most perfect election of
all time all right what are you talking
about if you have any complaints at all
shut up and go home meanwhile nancy
pelosi as late as 2019 was saying that
president trump was not a legitimately
elected president because of russian
hacking russian interference right so i
think let's see what the audit says
absolutely though we got to tighten up
election laws going forward we got to
look to 2022 going forward it's 2022 and
2024 and i do think we need
forward-looking substantive agendas
because if we win those elections
we still have a chance i think we can
put america back together and have a
prosperous american future if we lose
2022 and 2024
i think it's all over i don't think it's
been too dramatic to say it's all over
the dems will add
seats to the supreme court they will add
states to the union they will federalize
elections and then whatever you think
happened in 2020 as soon as hr 1 s1 as
soon as they get something like that
passed no republicans ever going to win
again in arizona or anywhere else all
right we'll get some more blake masters
in just one second first a reminder when
i'm on the road and i want to make sure
that my house is doing well everything's
good at home i have to use my ring alarm
security system and you should do it's
great when we move from california to
florida first thing my wife said get
that ring stuff on the house we did and
it's really easy to put it on the house
yourself you don't actually have to call
an expert to make it happen for you i'm
really a lot more at ease when i'm on
the road or away from home my ring alarm
equals peace of mind protect your home
with ring alarm ring alarm is a powerful
affordable whole home security system
you can easily install yourself it works
seamlessly with other ring products in
one simple app for a special offer go to
ring.com it's the perfect way to start
your ring experience you can keep an eye
on every corner of your house with the
indoor and outdoor cams you can see
what's happening right from your phone
protect your home anytime from anywhere
with ring alarm go to ring.com ben for a
special offer on a ring alarm security
kit today you can build a system that's
right for your home have it up and
running in just minutes that's ring.com
again ring dot com slash ben go check
them out right now ring.com slash ben i
wanna keep an eye on my kids make sure i
know what's going on all over my
property i rely on ring you should too
ring.com
so blake uh what is the the kind of
polling telling you at this point about
mark kelly's status uh he won very
narrowly against a lackluster candidate
in martha mcsally who actually lost
before obviously and then was appointed
to fill a seat after she had lost an
election already uh so now you're you're
running against kelly number one what is
the polling telly at number two where do
you think his chief sort of issue
vulnerabilities lie why are you the best
person to take those on
yeah his fave unfave ratio looks exactly
like any far left candidate who's you
know not been out there kirsten cinemas
taking the arrows for mark kelly at this
point so i think his favorables are
still
pretty high um but they're going down
they're going down with
the failures of the biden administration
i think those are going to sink
even more i don't think anyone thinks
the next 15 months are going to be
particularly good for the biden
administration or for the democrats and
so we'll have to make sure that people
know even though mark kelly is getting
out there and speaking in cliches even
though he won't get out there and tell
you what he actually thinks
he he must be in favor of this crazy uh
biden administration and their crazy
agenda because he just votes in lockstep
to serve it um and so i think we have
some some work to do there but you know
he he just ran because he's an astronaut
you know he stood by his his wife after
that horrific attack but he didn't have
a track record and this time he's
building up a track record and i think
his voters uh come to acquaint
themselves with that track record you
know they're going to be freaked out um
why am i the best person to to beat him
i do think it's hard to beat an
incumbent democrat we know this uh it's
going to take something fresh and new
and if you run the same kind of cookie
cutter candidates you'll get the same
kind of results and in arizona that
means narrow losses to democrats that
will increasingly be less narrow and so
i think we can't run someone boring i
think we can't run someone who's only
going to you know act like a politician
and do this weird thing with their hand
and tell you consultant-provided talking
points like people are sick of that and
you know i just i'm a millennial i'm 35
years old i think i have my finger on
the pulse of what's gone wrong in this
country not just in the in the last
eight months
of biden harris but also just in the
last couple of decades like i can speak
to this question of why do millennials
and zoomers feel like they're never
going to be able to afford a house why
does it feel like everything is a racket
you know designed to keep them down
because this is how people feel and the
problem is too many young people look at
that they feel jaded you know they stop
believing in the american dream and then
they go off to some far left bernie
sanders you know communist politics well
that doesn't work that's a dead end
right but i think a sort of common sense
healthy nationalism a real patriotism a
real focus on
how can we have a good american future
delivered by like a young person i think
that's a message people haven't heard
before in at least in quite a long time
so blake you're coming from the tech
world obviously and one of the things
that you talk pretty frequently about is
the the risks of big tech and the sort
of control that big tech has over our
lives what do you think is the best way
to handle uh the the threats that big
tech poses because on the one hand big
tech provides you know all sorts of
great
products and services at affordable
prices to people they they provide you
know facebook is free for people to use
it comes along with the risk that
facebook might deplatform you at any
moment meanwhile democrats have been
openly threatening big tech saying that
if they don't do what democrats want
them to do then there will be
consequences for that so if you're
you're a libertarian leading person what
do you think is the the best solution to
deal with the possible predations of big
tech
yeah well i'm not that libertarian on
big tech um and i used to be and i think
you got to update as time goes on and
these companies show themselves first of
all they've just gotten more and more
powerful every year right and at this
point google buys one company a week
they have for 15 years mostly in order
to quash it right so i think there's a
lot of anti-competitive conduct even on
traditional antitrust grounds but
i think we give them the whole kitchen
sink i think section 230 protections
should be repealed if these companies
want to act like publishers not
platforms um i'm interested in in
treating these companies like common
carriers right the phone company can't
kick you and i off uh because we have a
conversation about your you know right
leaning podcast so why should facebook
or twitter be able to do that um i'm
interested in exploring antitrust right
maybe some of these laws you mentioned
facebook was free well a lot of the
antitrust laws were written you know to
protect people from price gouging um
facebook doesn't price gouge the product
is free for you to use because you are
the product in some sense and so i think
the up uh uh the ftc anti-trust regime
we need to update all those laws to
apply to big tech but then i'm i'm even
interested in going after just the
addictiveness
or the the business model of targeted
advertising itself we'll get some more
blake masters in just one second first
let's talk about the fact that there's a
lot of pent-up demand in the economy
like millions of jobs that are yet to be
filled well it's hard to find great
employees in that kind of market i mean
you have more open jobs and you have
people seeking those jobs so where are
businesses turning to fill those roles
fast zip recruiter right now you can try
it for free at zippercrew.com dailywire
when you post a job on zip recruiter
they send your job to over 100 top job
sites giving you access to their network
of millions of job seekers zip
recruiters matching technology scans
resumes to find qualified candidates for
your open roles proactively presents
them to you you can easily review
recommended candidates and invite your
top choices to apply for your job that
encourages them to apply faster
according to zip recruiter internal data
jobs where employers invite candidates
to apply get two and a half times more
candidates zipper cruise technology is
so effective that four out of five
employers who post unzip recruiter get a
quality candidate within the very first
day so if you're looking to fill a job
zipper crew is the place to go head on
over to zip recruiter for free exclusive
web address try them out sip
recruiter.com dailywire that's
ziprecruiter.com
d-a-i-l-y-w-ire ziprecruit.com dailywire
zip recruiter is indeed the smartest way
to hire there's a reason their
technology is so effective the four out
of five employers who post on
ziprecruiter get a quality candidate
within day one go check them out right
now ziprecruiter.com
dailywire
alrighty blake so let's talk a little
bit about big tech and and some of the
measures that you were talking about
with regard to to what can be done to
rein in the predations of big tech
yeah i think uh i think we need to do a
whole lot here actually i don't think we
have a meaningful first amendment in
this country in just a few short years
if we do nothing if we're too lazy fair
frankly about big tech uh and so i think
we repeal section 230 protections right
if these companies want to talk uh
if they want to put their thumb on the
scale if they want to be publishers not
platforms fine but we'll treat them as
such um i think they should be common
carriers you know i think we should
break them up there's no reason why
facebook should be able to own facebook
classic and whatsapp and instagram and
sort of efficiently mine data from
people on each platform and share it
behind the scenes uh you know with the
facebook octopus so that they can you
know better and more surgically deliver
targeted advertising um but ultimately i
think the problem here
is that big tech is addictive um you
know i
i every venture capitalist i know that
has kids doesn't let their kids play
with iphones
or ipads
you know they all buy hand-carved wooden
swedish toys for their kids to play with
meanwhile you go to applebee's uh you
know or some family restaurant
and you you look at
dinner table conversations or what ought
to be conversations among family members
and every kid has his own ipad and
they're just like glued to it
and so i think
we got to recognize this is this is
really bad especially it's really bad
for for young people but you know it's
that cliched line the smartest minds of
my generation are figuring out how to
get people to click ads and i think all
this data that whole targeted
advertising business model
these products are engineered to be
addictive and i think manipulative and
and predatory so i think we need smart
young competent people in government who
know how
know how these businesses work and know
how we can do something about this it's
really interesting there is an article
about how china uh is now barring
students during school days from from
using a lot of these apps from playing
video games uh the idea of being on the
weekends that's fine but you know during
the school week you actually have to do
your work meanwhile the united states
where we're getting rid of things like
actually giving grades and and
and any sort of metric for testing
right
right i mean chinese model is probably
wrong you know that's usually the case
and um
it's also true that china
is deadly serious uh about many of the
problems they face and they're at least
willing to recognize sometimes hey we
have a problem here right and their
solutions are authoritarian and horrible
but so often the united states we just
uh act like ostriches with our head
buried in the sand there's no big tech
problem everything's fine this is just
the market at work you know meanwhile
yeah kids are addicted to their iphones
they're cutting class to vape
in you know school bathrooms or
something like this
um
i think this stuff is bad uh and we need
to be able to recognize that if we want
any prayer of being able to solve these
problems so blake one of the issues i'm
sure that's going to come up a lot in
this election is going to be your
association with peter thiel who's
become a sort of bugaboo for the left
the idea being that he is a almost
right-wing libertarian crypto fascist
george soros figure for folks who don't
know about what exactly peter thiel does
what the feel foundation is maybe you
can talk about that a little bit
yeah i mean i think peter's you know the
best or certainly one of the best tech
investors of of all time um
that's his day job but of course he's
very politically active and he uh made
waves in silicon valley when he publicly
supported then candidate donald trump uh
you know i think very early on in in
2016. and it's weird because i think
silicon valley like there's still a lot
of republicans it might be
30 might be 20 but it's 70 or 80
democrat and the politics the dynamic is
such that you cannot voice support uh
for the republican you know nominee or
the republican president everyone just
feels silenced than they are
um it's it's it's cancel culture it's
everything even the rich people
tend to be really straight jacketed but
what i really respect about peter is
he's like nope
sorry i'm gonna speak my mind um you
know and and he did and he was a very
public surrogate for
for trump and he just he just doesn't
care he's willing to to take the heat
from the left to stand up for what he
believes in i mean he's willing to
criticize trump too you know i mean he
doesn't think the administration is
perfect but he thinks it was pretty darn
good and a whole lot better than where
we'd be without trump right we'd be in
year five of a hillary clinton
presidency um that apparently is what
everyone in silicon valley was
salivating over uh and so look on the
teal capital side we invest in startup
technology companies you know i hope
they become very big and successful
spacex airbnb stuff like that and on the
teal foundation side the non-profit
we try to do what i call
anti-philanthropy philanthropy um what
are some good non-profit causes that we
can further that very few other people
are gonna donate to because they're not
maybe as socially fashionable and so our
best program i think is the teal
fellowship where we pay talented young
people a hundred thousand dollars to uh
drop out of college and instead work on
a business i think those businesses
together have been fantastically
successful but mainly it's the statement
against college right like why have we
built a society where we pretend that
the only value you can have as a human
being you know is to is to go through
this meat grinder where you get a
bachelor's degree uh at the end of it i
think that's insane most people probably
shouldn't go to college um especially
today where you go and it's just more
and more expensive doesn't actually make
any sense you come out of it
indoctrinated even less of a free
thinker than when you came in and so we
want to just shine a light there should
be a lot more paths to success in
society than just that one
once blake masters running against mark
kelly in arizona really appreciate the
time blake and good luck in the race
hey thank you ben appreciate it
the battle for the culture is heating up
we here at the daily wire are making
some big moves so be sure to like
subscribe ring that bell because you're
not going to want to miss a single
moment